si je pouvais revenir en arrière et que
je croisais cariste à orly je ferai la
même chose mais en mieux
six jeunes l'octogone derrière jean mais
crottes de nez
à l'époque je le comprends toujours je
suis le pop bien sûr je les comprends
moi déjà je comprends même pas comment
certaines personnes arrivent à survivre
avec si peu d'argent avec si peu de
moyens
je suis pas quelqu'un qui peut supporter
de ne pas s'occuper de ses enfants
j'ai pas demandé avec mon père
parce qu'ils ont beaucoup plus d'amour
de
[Musique]
bonjour nouba bonjour route alors je dis
booba mais d'abord comment est-ce que
comment est ce qu'on doit dire moi je me
pose la question
booba b2o mes proches m'appellent comme
capcom soldats anglais comme ça vient
d'eux et l'hélicoptère robocop parce que
élise on rappelle que c'est c'est mon
prénom prénom de prénom de naissance
comment ça va quelques jours après ce
qui s'est passé à une fusillade a eu
lieu pendant le tournage du dernier clip
du rappeur booba tout va bien dieu merci
ce qui me soutient
ce qui était le plus important c'est que
mon ami qui c'est qui s'est fait tirer
dessus ray bien vu qu'il est déjà sur
pied
comme on dit c'est que c'est signer ou
pas l'agression en clair à ce qu'est ce
que est ce que c'est car is des hommes
de qari ce jeune avocat de hockey ça
peut être
fred de sky qui m'envoie une équipe ça
peut être plein de gens ça peut être
beaucoup d'ennemis de bourgogne pourtant
je suis gentil à la bosse mais ce que tu
dis les risques du métier
ce que tu dis c'est que tu sais qui
c'est de rome
ce que je dis c'est que toutes ces
scènes est-ce que parfois tu te dis que
ça pourrait très très mal finir il va y
avoir un mort bien sûr bien sûr ça pour
ça pas mal fini mais mme kennedy s'est
pris une balle dans la tête a donc en
fait on fait une musique à haut risque
on va dire on a un certain passé on a
certaines habitudes certaines bonnes ni
certaines mauvaises
et puis voilà ça c'est le jeu on fait
attention et puis c'est parce qu'on
cherche bien sûr mais c'est une
éventualité
la mort c'est une éventualité bah rien
n'est plus sûr que la mort mais dans
dans une de mes chansons je me souviens
plus laquelle je fais longtemps je
disais aussi gerin trentaine je suis au
max max plus + 42 là c'est ça que ça
veut dire que la mort qui pense
régulièrement tu te dis que la mort
accident c'est cette fois que j'y pense
c'est pas que je pense régulièrement
c'est que c'est une chose j'en ai pas
vraiment peur
bon maintenant maintenant j'ai des
enfants donc c'est un peu différent je
suis encore plus attention mais ça fait
partie de la vie je veux dire tous les
jours tous les jours c'est une victoire
non tous les jours c'est un jour de
gagné voilà je veux dire tout peut
arriver ça va tellement vite il ya un
ouragan qui arrive par exemple sur c'est
un autre danger
voilà il ya une visite sur le tournage
de mon clip des accidents et des
maladies
est ce que cette agression de lemay
parce que c'est ce qui s'est passé et
remet en cause le combat l'octogone
combats d'arts martiaux d'entre vous et
charisme est-ce que ça ça remet en cause
le combat la fusionne en sort met pas en
cause le convoque pas du tout enfin ça
ça remettra en cause si ça devait être
organisé en france je pense que ce
serait impossible à organiser à cause
des autorités mais le combat est
toujours d'actualité ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que bon car ici jouent pas
le jeu il insulte les organisateurs y va
il parle de conférence de presse de
l'affrontement à 100 contre sens de
purge et c'est donc ce qui est anti
sportif alors qu'à la base on essaie on
essaie d'organiser un combat entre lui
et moi
donc il est sous contrat et la signer un
contrat
on peut pas sortir du contrat comme ça
on est pas neymar voilà c'est lui ni moi
et que c'est toujours d'actualité le
seul souci c'est de trouver une salle
qui accepte de le faire je veux pas trop
parler parce qu'on a beaucoup parlé a
rien entre guillemets mais la prochaine
fois qu'on parle de l'octogone
officiellement ça n'aurait pas tardé on
devrait avoir une salle avec la plaie
avec l'autorisation des deux de la
police de l'état et c'est l'état c'est
derrière l'état suisse le cessna en
suisse ça doit toujours se rend suisse
est toujours le 30 novembre à ça bouge
pas non ça ça bouge pas toujours le 30
novembre 20h pourquoi est-ce que tu
tiens absolument à le faire ce combat je
tiens absolument à le faire parce que il
ya beaucoup d'argent en jeu
parce que j'ai envie de lui casser la
bouche parce que j'ai commencé à
m'entraîner deux fois par jour à faire
de la natation j'ai acheté des masques
de plongée
j'ai arrêté le sucre j'ai mal partout
j'ai des courbatures
donc j'ai envie d'en terminer et puis
instagram c'est marrant cinq minutes
mais là je trouve que la cage c'est
beaucoup plus intéressant beaucoup plus
jouissif
j 2
voilà tu disais c'est antisportif le
comportement de charisme ça veut dire
que pour toi c'est du sport en fête a
bien sûr ça reste l'histoire on est dans
une cale c'est dj ju jitsu brésilien de
la boxe thaïlandaise la boxe anglaise
c'est du sport à 100%
moi j'ai deux entraînements par jour en
ce moment là à miami
ouais enfin là je viens de rentrer donc
j en vois je reprends tout à l'heure à 4
heures j'ai des entraînements par jour
le matin à l'après midi je dois faire
une sieste
tu vois j'ai passé moins de temps avec
mes enfants des cours de piano pour
c'est vrai la méditation
comment ces cours de piano en vue d'
octobre non pour en vue mais ça fait
partie de mon je pense je vais me
refaire game of thrones le soir pour
priver de cette sortie réelle
voilà restez donc c'était dans mon
objectif
ton dernier titre glen il commence comme
ça sera beaucoup moins bien de toi je te
préviens j'espère sinon je te passe
directe ne crois tu pas ce que je ne
conduis pas que je sais ce que je fais
tellement l'autriche de la guerre
tellement longtemps que je fais la
guerre la guerre à qui bat la guerre à
tous les to tatou ce qui a tout aussi
kilovolts à tous et à tous ceux qui nous
en vol je veux dire depuis le début j'ai
des idées
des tracteurs des gens qui veulent ma
place qui veulent le trône donc tu es
habitué j'ai l'habitude est souvent je
suis pas je suis pas devin je suis pas à
marboz mais souvent je connais souvent
je me mets dans des histoires et je
connais je connais la fin avant d'avoir
j'ai pas besoin de voir la fin du film
soit et c'est quoi la fin du film en
général ils des missiles à la toujours
en place si j'assume pas si je suis
faible on le prend le trou et si je
réponds pas aux attaques si je peux des
combats je perds le trône voilà la suite
des paroles c'est le prochain ces dames
sont le prochain se nomme ce bref madame
sauce et plus c'est plus à la rigolade
ce que je le connais c'est pas vraiment
c'est pas du tout lui vient pas et
vieillir a pas de fusillades avec nous
c'est plus bas j'aurais pas encore il à
être était il nous est traitée de [ __ ]
alors qu'on l'a aidé on a on a construit
sa carrière m'a aidé sans lui enlever
tout le temps qu'il a rincé c'est aussi
dû à son talent mais on l'a vraiment
là vraiment aidé on a vraiment kiffé le
l'artiste etc
on a on a beaucoup bossé sans projet on
a partagé on l'a aidé et puis à la fin
de son contrat et 2013 les maisons 10,2
[ __ ]
c'est ça que tu as pas aimer en fait
trop j'ai apprécié à moitié comme dirait
freud de sky
dams osséja c'est un gentil c'est pas je
sais même pas si facile fais du sport je
n'aime pas si c'est courir qui sont
intéressants ce qui est intéressant avec
car il sait qu'il a une grande gueule
c'est que il a un peu costaud il a dit
qu'il allait voir mon sens brisé les os
qui sera qui sent qu'ils sont en train
un peu à la boxe donc c'est intéressant
je trouve que la fiche allait elle est
pas mal celui de briser les oujdis boire
tout sens et puis c'est un peu c'est moi
qui l'ait c'est un peu père fils c'est
moi qui l'ait c'est moi qui les fais de
toutes pièces il se retourne contre son
père donc je te le corriger donc
l'histoire à l'air elle est belle
il y en a pas mal des clashs depuis le
début de ta carrière ce qu'il faut dire
aussi je te coupe c'est que j'ai parlé
souvent comme le mec qui n'ont que la
secte monde mais fo ne faut pas oublier
que je suis je suis dans le game depuis
plus de vingt ans donc c'est aussi
normal que que j'ai un lourd passé un
historique de clash peu de oued au clash
en général peu de gens dure aussi
longtemps dans mon métier mais est-ce
qu'il ya quelque chose que tu aimes dans
le clash
par ailleurs je moi je suis un
compétiteur je suis un sportif de base
depuis tout petit donc et j'aime pas
être en tort les classes j'en ai démarré
aucun don quoi ça me ça met un peu de
ces épices et quoi ça et puis c'est un
peu le truc quand je suis pas encore à
combien tac ça me dérange pas forcément
ça me ça me donne un petit coup de
booste ça motive
toi t'as que jamais le premier sac
unique non enfin tous les clowns et j'ai
jamais attaqué rohff la fouine caris
et tu te dis jamais bon allez on arrête
les clash on se reparle
je repars la dame se serait par la carie
ce nom c'est de ce nom en général quand
ça casse ça casse comme avec les meufs
quand ça casse et pas de ne pas de pause
le bo de break et il n'y a pas de retour
possible
c'est ça qu'est ce que le regret c'est
un sentiment que tu connais parfois
est-ce que tu regrettes des choses
franchement n'ont pas vraiment de
regrets
pas de place pour les rôles parlants
pour le regret le temps par non non
parce que je suis quelqu'un d'assez
réfléchi qu'on le croit ou non
donc même dans la même dans le clash
mène dans la guerre chez quand même où
je mets les pieds chez ce que je fais
j'assume mes actes mais propos voilà
comme l'été dernier j'étais en prison
n'ont pas trop à prendre et j'assume je
me suis battu dans l'aéroport je vais en
prison
je ressors la vie continue je peux en
train de pleurer donc par exemple leur
dire je te dirai pas si si si je pouvais
revenir en arrière et que je croisais
carissa orly je ferai la même chose mais
en mieux
ça ressemblerait quoi ce sera encore
plus violent mais changera pas je
regrette pas du tout
si tu perds il se passe quoi
c'est pardon c'est super
je sais pas je ne sais pas je peux pas
j'ai pas le droit de perdre
pourquoi c'est pas bon si tu perds
parce que c'est c'est le clash des
titans
ça fait tellement de bruit a tellement
l'histoire est tellement profonde et
ancienne et c'est ça les arènes c'est
leur toit
c sérums celui qui perd hyper tu vois si
vous dire c'est c'est mohamed ali
frasier au congo c'est l'honneur ces
gladiateurs
si j -l l'octogone derrière je vends mes
crottes de nez si je le perds je les
vends pas elles vont rester dans mon
genre si tu les perds tu disparais de la
scène pas je partirai pas excusé
disparaît tout le monde disparaît si
s'arrêterait pas tout ça mais j'ai le
sentiment qui a rien qui te fait peur en
fait c'est vrai ou ses activités jeudi
au final c'est juste on en fait tout un
fromage mais c'est juste un combat de 2
mm à ses trois rounds de cinq minutes
ces 15 minutes dans une vie donc faut
relativiser il ya des gens qui vivent
sous les bombes donc on va dire ça met
la pression mais peur c'est pas ça qui
va me faire peur l'ouragan en catégorie
cinq toques vapeur one en catégorie 4/5
je fus octobre ne fut pas est-ce que tu
as le sentiment qu'on te connaît mal est
ce que ça te dérange d'ailleurs c'est ce
que va dire le sentiment que oui je peux
être incompris mais c'est normal
le vus de l'extérieur ça ça doit être
tellement compliqué que ça me dire ce
que je le comprends mais ça me dérange
pas d'être mal compté puisque tant que
moi je sais je sais qui je suis je suis
en paix avec moi-même j'assume mes actes
je sais où je vais donc moi j'ai pas de
problème
le problème est qu avec ça ça ça fait
partie du truc
on met monde déteste c'est très bien oui
je t'attendais à la radio l'autre jour
et tu parlais
du dormeur du val de rimbaud je pense
qu'il ya plein d'auditeurs de france
inter qui à l'époque
enfin ce moment là on nous dira et dubaï
connaît un beau ou pas être allé à
l'école bien sûr je connais un bon comme
tout le monde et ça te dérange pas non
mais je coche par le ton image ça te
dérange pas que les gens se disent que
c'est pas possible
donc ça me dérange pas je suis tellement
habituée de toute façon c'est pas grave
j'ai jamais voulu être célèbre j'ai fait
de la musique ça m'est tombé dessus
après je fais avec pour les choses comme
elles viennent mais je veux dire c'est
pas grave qu'on aime ou on n'aime pas
t'as jamais voulu être célèbre
non sérieux j'ai toujours voulu avoir de
l'argent normal mais pas pourquoi parce
que l argent égale liberté
j'ai toujours voulu être libre en fête
est pour moi la liberté c'est avoir de
l'argent c'est de se dire ok demain je
pars à moscou ramos que ça me fait chier
je rêvais en france je veux manger un
grec
donc je vais manger leurs restaurants
étoilés voilà je m'achète telle ou telle
voiture je prends le bus mais la liberté
ça imprime quelqu'un qui gagne 1200
membres 1200 euros par mois baïla jamais
on m'a dit vivre à jamais
une coupe du monde on sera les lira
jamais dans la navette d'elon musk dans
l'espace etc etc a rejoint seynois ses
trésors l'argent égale liberté tu as un
avocat commis d'office n'a pas d'argent
tu restes en prison tu as de l'argent
d'un bon avocat
tu sors de prison et c'est donc moi mon
but c'est d'avoir de l'argent simplement
sans advienne même sans être vénale
c'est juste pour moi c'est synonyme de
liberté cd clé donc la prison tu la
connais à quatre reprises la dernière
fois c'était à fleury après la bagarre à
orly quand on n'a pas connu la prison il
ya des fantasmes de dunks sur la prison
ça fait peur la prison comment ça se
passe en fait la vie en prison il ya
prison de mes débuts
les fleuristes c'était différent parce
que la prison mes débuts j'avais commis
des crimes
donc j'étais pas vraiment surpris d'y
être a sonné aussi juste milieu entre
guillemets mais je veux dire j'étais
dans un contexte criminelle
là c'était plus à la cool puisqu'on sait
juste une bagarre au final ça c'est face
à l'euro à l'aéroport c'était en réunion
dieu merci personne a été blessée en
dehors d'eux
[Musique]
des deux groupes je peux dire y'a pop
il n'y a pas une petite fille ou une île
d'amour monsieur qui a caressé les
projectiles qui a reçu des coups donc
c'est rester entre nous donc je savais
qu'en fait j'avais paraissait montant
prévu que je connaissais déjà prises ont
cédé à mes petites habitudes
donc j'étais pas perdu j'avais déjà j'y
serai j'y resterai pour un mois maximum
je connais la loi cj été plusieurs fois
donc j'étais assez détendue entre nîmes
et sa manette vers mire un peu de me
reposer je dis pas que c'est super la
prison je sais c'est horrible et je
souhaite à personne mais je veux dire
dans mon cas c'était presque de la
promouvoir
je savais que j'allais rester un mois
max toute chose qui a pas grand chose on
ça m'a coûté un peu d'argent mais voilà
c'était notre expérience mais tu disais
la liberté c'est la chose la plus
importante pour toi quand tu es en
prison tu as tout sauf la liberté j'ai
tout sauf la liberté mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que c'était temporaire
c'est pas comme si j'étais dans une
enquête criminelle que j'avais braquer
une banque ou tuer quelqu'un il faut que
je suis un mandat de dépôt criminel et
clochers que j'avais dû
et dans deux ou trois ans que j'avais 7
ans je veux dire c'est un autre contexte
là c'est une bagarre et
jordi tt maximum voilà je n'ai pas
inquiète
et quand on n'est pas bon gars et qu'on
est en prison ça peut vite être l'enfer
on abat prison c'est comme je dis je le
saut je le souhaite à personne
sebbar c'est la petite mort
c'est la petite mort
[Musique]
quand je une question je me pose c'est
que quelqu'un comme emmanuel macron
qu'est salut menu un peu le président
business man c'est l'image qu'il avait
quand il est arrivé au pouvoir co
président business one he man vont ils y
aller un rapport à l'entreprise oil et
gilet jaune tous les week-ends superbe
business s'est passé pas un président
élu salut tu me parles d'un gilet jaune
tu as suivi un peu la crise de gilet
jaune dessinée de miami même de paris je
vais souvent à paris dans tous les mois
et demi deux mois je suis tu t'es dit
quoi à ce moment-là je me dis que c'est
fantastique c'est incroyable que toutes
les semaines ils ont envahi les champs
elysées alors qu'on est un peu parti du
g8
c'est la plus belle avenue du monde on a
les meilleurs vins c'est complètement
ses lunettes pour moi mais tu es
comprend ces gens là a bien sûr le grand
s'est enfin ce que je crois à l'époque
je le comprends toujours je suis le
peuple
bien sûr je les comprends
moi je comprends même pas comment
certaines personnes arrivent à survivre
avec si peu d'argent avec si peu de
moyens
ça va pas du tout tu parle pas beaucoup
de politiques dans des textes mais
parfois quand même quand même c'est quoi
les choses quand je regarde la télé où
tu écoute la radio tu lis des journaux
c'est quoi les choses qui te révolte
dans l'actu qui te font réagir qui te
font pleurer je sais pas derrière le
dernier truc qui me fait sourire
tellement c'est c'est tragique
c'est un sourire nerveux c'est les
migrants par exemple au camp babagana
base notamment quand j'étais à fleury et
que du coup j'étais dans ma cellule je
dois me taper les info et bfm et c'est
en boucle je vais pas donc ça va
regarder donc du coup je voyais que et
que dès que des misères forcément et
c'était je me rappelle il y avait les
affaires de prêtres pédophiles
personne n'est personne n'a inquiété
personne n'est mis en garde à vue
incroyable il y avait quoi il y avait
les migrants où on laissait les bateaux
au large avec des femmes enceintes et
des
des gens des hommes des femmes des
enfants en train de mourir et que
c'était la guerre pour savoir qui allait
les accueillir non pas chez moi pas chez
moi je trouve ça incroyable c'est sans
casser cet été l'arrière bien le pen qui
restait en mer à 100 ça n'a pas fini de
se passer la colline du crack à paris
pour un support la mémoire de la
colonisation tiens c'est quelque chose
qui t'a kita vachement marqué je prends
ce qui m'a vachement marqué c'est que je
n'y ai pas de devoir de mémoire par
rapport à la colonisation
on nous en informe qu'on nous en parle
jamais à l'école et qu'on passe comme si
c'était limite normal quoi ou pas grand
chose moi j'ai appris dont en fait ça
m'a marqué parce que j'ai appris dans le
dur je suis allée petit en afrique
je suis allé à l'île de gorée donc quand
tu vas à l'île de gorée tu vois tu vois
les cellules avec les les bars de les
barres de fer les chaînes les cellules
pour les nouveau nés les cellules pour
les
femmes les cellules pour les hommes les
cellules pour les
et les ormes en mauvaise santé amaigri
en train de mourir kong avait comme des
oies l'huile de palme pour qu'ils
prennent du poids et qu'ils puissent
survivre au voyage
quand tu vois ça à 10 ans que tu es de
père sénégalais et de mère française qui
donc à un moment je pense se sont aimés
et moins ça c'est encore plus des routes
on se trouve
ouais c'est ce que j'avais à dire tu dis
j'ai un peu le cul entre deux chaises en
tant que métisse mais me you mieux vaut
avoir le cul entre deux chaises que deux
chaises entre le cul pour la petite
punchline donc quand et où est ce que tu
disais quand elle franco-sénégalais tu
te dis quoi tu te dis j'ai une partie de
ma famille qui a peut-être été il ya non
c'est même pas ça c'est que je me dis
comment on peut être aussi aussi
diabolique
ça me regarde une cellule pour les
nouveaux nés
j'ai passé tout coup c'est comme la
shoah quand tu vois les contrôles c'est
dingue chose que je sais comment comment
on en arrive là
comment l'homme a pu faire ça mais
comment il est capable de faire ça c'est
incompréhensible pour moi c'est un degré
de violence de c'est surnaturel pour
vous est ce qu'on parle d'eux et on fait
comme si on n'en parle pas laval attend
pas oui moi mais moi je suis qui battait
suivie par des millions et des millions
de vies oui mais bon c'est pas suffisant
c'est pas suffisant mais bon c'est déjà
ça on parle d'actualité la moyenne une
chose qui m'a toujours marqué c'est que
la religion c'est pas ton truc
la religion c'est que je me suis
intéressé
je suis de ma famille musulmane
ma mère n'est pas croyante c'est pas que
ça voir mon truc c'est que je trouve que
c'est personnel et que j'aime pas trop
afficher pour moi c'est pas c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on doit afficher qu'on
soit religieux ou pas je pense pas que
ça doit être un critère de
est-ce que tu as encore des rêves ouais
mais d'emglev justement jeudi j'ai trop
d'âge est trop d'argent je ne rêve plus
mais hamdoullah agetu danse ça veut dire
que je n'aurais flux j'accomplis voix si
demain je dis ouais et je rêve d'aller
dans l'espace je ne rêve pas de en
espagne achète un billet pour aller dans
l'espace ça que ça veut dire mais et des
rêves qui sont pas liées à l'argent
comme quoi je n'ai pas rencontré
quelqu'un rencontré quelqu'un en
particulier faut que j'arrive en
lamborghini n'a pas me regarder
on se présente on rencontrait quelqu'un
en particulier de la new york poutine
pour voir chez bach il doit être suivi
j'aimerais bien discuter avec l'aviron
plat des murs poutine ou un scientifique
toi les scientifiques qui veulent que
les gouvernements une cache et qui
disent que voilà en cinq ans le lag la
soul à la montée des eaux montée des
eaux qui nous parle chiffres réalité une
cache parce qu'ici à miami on est
concerné par la montée des eaux a bien
sûr ils ont déjà élevé les routiers à 2
ans source us beach ça veut dire que
l'environnement c'est un sujet qui te
qui préoccupe de l'avenir de la planète
le joola en plus c'est peut-être à cause
de mes joueurs non mais de plus en plus
je pense que ça va ça va pas tarder à
partir en couille sérieusement ne pas
faire flipper la la planète mais je
pense que j'ai un petit pressentiment je
pense qu'on me cache beaucoup de choses
même là la conquête spatiale est ici
soit ils sont à fond dans plus qu'eux et
on n'en parle même plus elle ne rate pas
d'ombré des trucs dans l'espace et c'est
d'aller sur mars
l'amazonie brûle depuis trois semaines
il ya deux je regarde la télé joue à
breaking news c'est breaking news de
quoi ça fait trois semaines ça bride
alors que c'est censé être le poumon de
la planète et baleines échouées sur la
il ya plein de trucs qui ne se sent pas
très bon je trouve
non mais booba écolo c'est une info
qu'un mois
après je veux te parler
pas encore
je vois pas trop lent 4 4 mais tu te dis
déjà parfois comme là on parle de sa
belle peut-être que faut plus jouer en 4
4 que je fasse gaffe à la clim en aux
etats unis c'est bizarre mais non non
c'est les contradictions que tous les
êtres humains quand ça va ça donne quoi
qu'il arrive c'est pas à moi de c'est
trop tard c'est pas
tassel knife de quoi de penser qu'on
peut changer c'est trop tard je tenais
aussi à des choses non mais c'est pas à
nous c'est ccc à ce qu'on les bons les
manettes de changer mon c dessus tu peux
pas dans des gens lambda qui veut pas
leur demander à eux de changer la
planète et tu te dis pas on peut tous y
contribuent
c'est mais ça se fera pas c'est comme si
je te dis il ya assez de nourriture pour
nourrir toute la planète devrait pas y
avoir de famine dans le monde maintenant
on ne devrait pas y en a il ya une
question que je me pose et je pense que
plein de gens se posent c'est quoi le
quotidien de booba à miami en gros est
ce que booba quand il est là avec ses
enfants c'est monsieur tout le monde
ah bah oui comme c'était tout à l'heure
ici je suis super connu c'est rare qu'on
me reconnaisse quelques français serge
litchi
monsieur tout le monde heureusement
c'est à dire au savs le matin
on fait petit déjà sa fille on m'amène à
l'école exactement je suis je sèche les
cheveux
des fois je la coiffe je l'aide à à
mettre son tee shirt et j'ai fait son
bol de céréales j'en à l'école de la
chercher je suis à la boxe je reviens je
l'emmène au parc
heureusement je serais malheureux si je
crois si je pouvais pas m'occuper d'eux
c'est la base sata révolutionner
l'arrivée de tes enfants mais qu'est ce
que tu pensais à ce point là que sa
lettre révolutionner non mais j'étais
prêt
j'en étais j'étais conscient que enfin
je sais que c'est en moi je suis pas je
suis pas quelqu'un qui peut supporter de
ne pas s'occuper de ses enfants de les
voir d'être séparé de de les voir que
pendant les grandes vacances ou en
week-end sur deux à cinq mois
est-ce que c'est des enfants différents
de l'enfant que que tu étais toi à leur
âge
est-ce que tu dois en es que est ce
qu'il ya des choses des erreurs ce qui
sont beaucoup plus je pense qu'ils ont
beaucoup plus de chances entre
guillemets beaucoup plus attention à ma
mère me n'aime pas donner d'intention
mais j'ai pas demandé avec mon père
parce qu'ils ont beaucoup plus d'amour
de
s'en plaindre un sens critique et mes
parents où ma mère m'a toujours elle m'a
bien élevés etc mais ils ont une
meilleure vie tes enfants les voient
surtout ta fille pour l'instant on y
voit beaucoup sur internet sur les
réseaux
ils m'ont pris s'il est bon il est pas
trop c'est pas trop un showman pourquoi
est-ce que tu laisses comme moi tu les
mets en scène où elle pourquoi est-ce
qu'elles reculaient un peu en scène
comme ça sur les raisons en fait je la
mets en scène parce que c'est
c'est elle qui s'élançait en fait ces
races et une énergie brute elle rayonne
et se met à chanter pour moi je la
trouve incroyable donc ses marques
hummer et aussi parce que je me permets
de faire ça aussi puisque japon jamais
pour en france si j'habitais en france
je pense que j'ai démontrera bras parce
que tu deviens qu'à l'école s'appelle à
ce que j'ai envie qu'on les reconnaisse
dans la rue etc et qui ici ils sont
tranquilles écueils sont entre
guillemets protéger dans l'anonymat les
les références artistiques
je t'ai entendu cité cabrel renault
évidemment mistral gagnant qui a été
samplé dents sur pitbull ouais on va se
recentrer
mistral gagnant avec des chansons de bob
marley est ce qu il yad autres référence
de la chanson française
est-ce que ça va jusqu'à piaf brel
brassens
moi je suis sensible au texte
donc ouais mais c'est qui ce qui ce qui
me parle elle puisque abrégé mais j'aime
beaucoup sa manière d'écrire il sera les
gagnants je trouve que c'est le
gottex jamais écrit pour moi gainsbourg
ça me parlait pas trop brassens c'est
pas trop non plus kaboré j'aime bien
cabrel et vivent encore je viens du ce
le jeu vient du ciel et les étoiles
entre elles ne parlent que de toi etc et
d'un musicien qui fait jouer ses
mauvaises images et voilà
mais que je disais il est vivant c'est
est ce que c'est un chanteur avec qui tu
aimerais chanter rapper non non pas du
tout
pourquoi que pas que ça me déplairait
mais c'est pas c'est pas parce que je
l'apprécié que j'ai envie de faire un
film ça va pas ça va pas ensemble
qu'est-ce que tu écoute toi comme
musique à part la tienne j'imagine à
part la mienne bas vous pouvez enfin la
mienne je les écoute plus dans le mode
dans le monde du travail
c'est plus par exemple j'écoute beaucoup
d'instruments l'instrument j'écoute mes
instruments et c'est les choix là
j'étais en train je prépare un featuring
j'étais en train d'écouter instrus
essayer de trouver l'inspiration glaive
qui est sorti on retrouve le timbre de
voix de booba en fait il n'ya pas il n'y
a pas de vocoder pour celle du rap à
l'ancienne
est-ce que l'album il sera comme ça où
l'album il sera ailleurs à tous je peux
pas dire il y aura peut-être du piano
voix guitare voix du globe du meilleur a
pas que du bluff c'est sûr je fais tout
moi j'ai un peu capable de tout faire de
chanter rapper le dur le glaive ziegler
cema c'est ma base c'est facile pour moi
tiers du globe c'est la routine quoi
tu disais je compte par ap jusqu'à 60
ans non tant à 42 ouais tu t'arrêtes
seront bientôt le plus tôt possible
quoique ça me déplaisent mais je pense
que je vais bientôt raccrocher le
maillot et passer plus de temps
peut-être sur d'autres artistes passer
plus de temps dans d'autres domaines
il ya des gens qui vont mourir la fin il
voyait grand talent c'est toujours de ma
faute
mais bientôt c'est vraiment ça peut être
quoi après cet album ça peut être des
votes après cet album où le prochain je
pense je pense pas en faire trois par
exemple pour donner une petit on se
pencher encore 3 les groupes mythiques
dans l'histoire ils sont en jeu 10 ans
de budget 30 on sait ça
penser qu'on avait un scoop mais gros
politique ils se reforment toujours à
jour est-ce que tu sois sincère ou pour
le business d'ailleurs ouais
est-ce que reformé lunetterie jours pour
le business est-ce que reformé lunatique
c'est possible ou pas impossible moi
c'est ce que tu disais c'est quand même
fonctionne pas comme une histoire
d'amour ça c'est du vrai c'est quoi
l'avenir de booba l'avenir de bois c'est
l'avenir de mes enfants
ça veut dire que pour que tout aille
bien pour que ça aille bien pour mais
sinon terrain pour être plus pour parler
business
des choses non je peux pas parler donc
forcément j'ai des projets l'octogone
j'espère une tournée après mon prochain
album que je suis en train de préparer
ces camps d'ailleurs il va sans dire
j'espère le sortir en 2020 j'ai ma
marque de vêtements disconnected qu'on
est en train de développer
je produis une dizaine d'artistes
ouais faut que j'aille dans l'espace
avec elon musk donc l'avenir il est
l'avenir est chargé l'espace avec un
masque c'est sérieux ça avec nos
demeures ou un autre mais depuis
quelques temps j'ai envie d'aller dans
l'espace
faut que je vois j'ai envie de boire